[Musik]
bongiorno herzlich willkommen zur
service jetzt gerade ganz verwirrt aber
egal
hallo und herzlich willkommen zur welt
heute gibt's ein italienisches rezept
von meiner freundin sally variante sagt
sie am besten gleich dazu nicht dass
jemand sagt das gehört original nicht so
und zwar geht es heute passt j das sind
kleine törtchen und ein mürbeteig gebäck
und innen habe ich die leckere creme
apart krämer pasta oder so
die ist wirklich super lecker und
traditionell wird das so gebacken dass
der mürbeteig dann geschlossen wird ich
habe jetzt mal ohne butter zucker noch
gelassen was man sieht ja aber auch eine
variante gemacht mit offen ich finde
beides schild muss auch gleich probieren
und wer möchte bestreut sie dann nach
dem backen abkühlen noch mit etwas süßem
schnee richtig schön und ihr könnt sie
dann eben mit dieser vanillecreme füllen
ich hab noch kirschen mit rein gegeben
lämmerhirt geht das im prinzip alles was
man möchte äpfel mit tipps zum beispiel
gehen auch richtig lecker und ich habe
noch ein bisschen tonkabohne dabei
vielleicht die italienische pendant für
sally leid und ich zeige euch jetzt die
zutaten für ihr werkzeug für den
mürbeteig brauche ich 250 gramm mehl 125
gramm kalte butter 70 gramm puderzucker
ein eigelb eine prise salz und jedoch
tonkabohne für die füllung brauche ich
500 milliliter milch 105 zucker etwas
vanille extrakt 50 kommt stärke 4 eigelb
200 gramm sahne und wer möchte 100 gramm
kirschen jetzt nicht zuerst einmal mit
dem müll kann der muss nämlich noch
kühlen dafür gebe ich jetzt die kalte
butter in die rührschüssel da kommt der
puderzucker mit dazu gemeinsam mit dem
salz und dann kann ich die masse erst
einmal kurz cremig rühren
jetzt wirklich noch das eigelb mit dazu
und etwas von der abgegebenen tonkabohne
zum schluss kommt jetzt noch das mehl
mit rein und so wird der teig verknetet
jetzt kann ich den mürbeteig mit den
händen zusammenfügen und dann für eine
halbe stunde bis stunde kühl stellen und
die zeit mit sich natürlich um die creme
vorzubereiten
[Musik]
jetzt wird die crema passiert ära
zubereitet also eine art pudding dafür
gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen milch in
einen kleinen topf da kommen die stärke
mit dazu und die eigelbe wird jetzt ganz
glatt gerührt
hier könnte ich jetzt auch schon den
zuckerinsel und durch das eike bekommt
die creme eine richtig tolle farbe jetzt
würde ich noch die restliche milch dazu
und für den geschmack manning extraktion
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die creme bei geringer
hitze während immer syrerin ganz ganz
langsam erhitzen und einmal kurz
aufkochen lassen
[Musik]
und damit die creme mit dem ofen nicht
zu fest wird kommt jetzt noch ein
bisschen sahne rein und das mache ich
jetzt auch schon vor dem abkühlen der
nach dem abkühlen wird sie noch fester
und da wird es durch ein bisschen
schwierig
[Musik]
jetzt lasse ich die creme schön abkühlen
und dafür fühle ich sehr einfach in ein
flaches schälchen dicksten oberfläche
direkt mit frischhaltefolie ab und dann
geht wieder weiter
wenn der pudding oder die creme
abgekühlt ist
[Musik]
jetzt streicht gerade noch die crema
durch ein haar sieht damit einfach
klümpchen entfernt werden
[Musik]
die kommt jetzt ganz kurz zur seite
und jetzt kann ich bereits den mürbeteig
nehmen und kurz durchkneten und dann auf
3 mm stecker ausrollen
wenn euch dieser teig zu möbel ist dann
könnt ihr übrigens auch den 123
mitnehmen hier habe ich ja das
verhältnis 1 2 4 also mail dann die
hälfte davon gut die hälfte davon zucker
oder verwendet einfach ein komplettes
einer hat man nämlich durch das eiweiß
noch ein bisschen mehr bindung so ist
der teig aber eben extrem möbel und das
mag ich total
mit einer großen palette löse ich dann
immer gerne den teig von der partie
und jetzt kann ich einen muffin blech
besprühen mit back trends gray
normalerweise hätte ich jetzt mein
martin blechschmidt hebe boden verwendet
damit ich die törtchen später einfach
heraus bekommt aber es hatte murat grad
verliehen also musik herkömmliches
marvin blech nehmen jetzt nehmt ihr euch
einen aus schlechter oder ein schälchen
zum beispiel was etwas größer ist als
die mav in form und da könnt ihr jetzt
diese kreise ausstechen
und dann die form damit auskleiden
[Musik]
wenn ihr habt könnt ihr auch so ein
hölzchen nehmen so eindrücke und könnte
das ganze dann damit so ein bisschen
eindrücken dann ist es einfacher und so
bekommt man zum beispiel auch die
kleidung schlüssel raus und jetzt könnt
ihr die törtchen mit der krämer befüllen
und je nachdem wie dick oder dünn wird
das ganze aus rollt entstehen sechs oder
mehr törtchen und hier könnt ihr jetzt
zum beispiel auch noch ein bisschen lärm
gehört einrühren oder äpfel mit rein
schneiden ich werde es einfach ein paar
kirschen noch mit rein linken
und aus dem teig rest steckt jetzt noch
kreise aus und damit werden die förmchen
geschlossen
aber ich bin es eigentlich auch ganz
schön und ich werde auch so machen ich
werde noch ein paar machen die oft sind
[Musik]
also wenn ihr die törtchen offenland
dann reicht der teig auf jeden fall für
zwölf wenn ihr mit deckel macht dann
muss man ein bisschen mehr teig
zubereiten oder weniger törtchen
ich setze jetzt hier noch ein paar
blümchen drauf dafür bestreitet den
deckel einfach mit ein bisschen wasser
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel gibt
aufstreichen dann bekommen die törtchen
auch bisschen farbe
und so kommen sie jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen und können
gebacken werden und nach dem backen
lasse ich sie komplett abkühlen und die
zwischenzeit nutze ich um die restlich
mit creme zu vermischen
[Musik]
ende sportlich ja nach dem backen habe
ich die törtchen die passwörter komplett
abkühlen lassen und sie lassen sich dann
mit einer winkel palette zum beispiel
richtig gut raus lösen also es geht echt
super jetzt natürlich vorführeffekt
nicht aber es klappt wirklich
hervorragend den winkel palette wurde
und plötzlich geht beides geht und dann
könnte sie nach dem abkühlen noch mit
etwas süßem schnee bestreut servieren
ok du darfst jetzt probieren ich bin
eine gute ehefrau daher gibt es noch
eine nettes restaurant ohr vor günstig
sind und waren so probiert kann ich
meine geschichte erzählen und zwar habe
ich das rezept von meiner freundin
jasmin und jetzt zeigt sich dass murat
nur einer kann die kamera haben entweder
du oder beim einer italienischen
freundin jasmin okay es hat sich
wirklich etwas halb italienerin und eben
fragt ziemlich unfälle inwieweit fisch
und dann habe ich sagt post risotto habe
ich fertig was habe ich noch gemacht er
am esstisch im kühlschrank süßkartoffel
formal sind carola habe ich auch gemacht
und sogar noch türkisches helmes steht
schon auf dem balkon und noch nicht
wissen weil sie wollen nämlich meine
super league machen sagt okay ich habe
sagt vielleicht angebracht jetzt
wahrscheinlich viel anderes nebenher
genommen
[Musik]
ja so cool gar in eine hälfte des tages
habe ich noch so mandl
tropical rain winter man mir beteiligt
wolf ein gern und das finde ich nehme
ich gern diesen 124 teig da ist nämlich
super möwe und klar das ausrollen schon
bisschen schwieriger aber mit geübten
händen finde ich klasse schmecken ja
wobei du solltest ja probieren war schon
den ganzen weg also nicht du solcher
probieren ob der mit deckeln
genauso gut schmeckt wie der ohnedies
könne also müsst ihr einfach probieren
macht auf jeden fall dieses rezept
danach probiert's aus einmal mit deckel
einmal ohne deckel und dann könnt ihr
mir ja schreiben was euch besser
schmeckt ich denke dass bei der variante
mit decken einfach die creme innen schön
weich bleibt und ohne deckel findet sich
als oben wahrscheinlich so nach haut und
wird dann vielleicht oben bisschen
fester ich glaube mir schmeckt beides
gut ich lasse jetzt auch ein espresso
ausprobieren törtchen und ihr findet das
rezept auf cds - blog.de
danke noch mal lieber für das rezept dem
moor abspeckt sei gut du bist ab sofort
die lieblings freunde von noch weitere
etage installieren diese rezepte
[Musik]